here's a story from military times
nearly 70% of active members are
overweight report fines
70% of active military duty is out is
overweight so a report of American
Security part reveals that two3 of
Americans uh of soldiers active duty
members fall within overweight or obese
category the body mass index BMI the
obesity rate within a military base on
BMI has more than doubled over the past
decade rising from are you kidding me
rising from 10 to 21% the report
emphasizes need for address ing this
issue particularly in the context of
military Recruitment and Readiness to
grow an obesity rate amongst service
members are seen as alarming affecting
the military's ability to recruit an
adequate labor force the report
recommends reviewing body composition
standards referring troops with high BMI
to specialized doctors for obesity
treatment with including BMI data and
Report provided to Congress what is the
recruiting and rtion what are we talking
about here what's your thoughts on the
story you tell well first of all Pat the
numbers for recruitment is at an all
like it's Tom nobody's joining the
military I'm actually worried Pat cuz
not only
70% out of shape is absolutely uh
ridiculous which has doubled in the past
10 years look at how what else has the
military been doing this year we lost
for a week uh F35 $85 million plane they
had no idea where the hell it was and
then they came out and asked the public
hey do you guys know where it is it's
like wait a minute you're the military
you know I mean how are you asking us
where a stealth fighter is I mean
apparently I think they found that crash
somewhere in the ocean but uh Pat I'm
genuinely worried cuz besides the weight
besides the losing technology not not
keeping up with what's happening in the
world with uh intelligence we're paying
the military pays for girls to have boob
jobs and if you want to transition
they'll they're paying for people to
have transition surgery your tax dollar
your tax dollar is going for that it's
the military is getting weak and with
all the stuff that's happening in the
world this is the worst time to have
overweight woke surgery having people
that are like when cuz Tom we're we
we've gotten LAX ofical because nothing
has happened there's there hasn't been
no Wars there hasn't been no deployments
it's it's it's a scary thing because I'm
not saying Pat we need practice but
something needs to happen with the
training and something needs to happen
Tom to keep them on their toes because
if 70% are overweight God forbid some
ground Invasion happens I think
we're in bad shape Tom I I I agree I
think it's part of a a bigger and longer
five week podcast on America's health
and and and what's going on but I think
this is this is disgraceful and but I go
Upstream why can't we get young people
with a patriotic eye to serve their
country well we you look what happening
in the schools and stuff we're having
trouble recruiting them and the ones we
can recruit we're having what they're
saying is I can't get enough people that
are in shape that want to defend their
country so I'm having to expand the
criteria
to people who are softer and bigger and
I think
that's P do you like no wonder why
numbers are down if you wave a flag
people are like you're you're you're
racist patriotism is at an all-time low
you can't even say that you love being
American CU people think that it's a
shitty thing to say that doesn't
surprise me so so by the way just
beautifully put together number one love
of the country you have to have that you
got to have love and pride for the
country you represent others have it uh
uh our educational system is not
increasing love and pride in our country
that's number one number two it's a very
good point Tom number two our standards
have dropped okay we are trying to be
way too soft allowing trans allowing you
know it's okay to do lgbtq and to do
this and to do that we have to be more
such and such your enemy doesn't give a
if you're gay stray trans or black
or white or Hispanic they don't care
they want to kill you and the only thing
you can do to protect your country is to
be seen feared and respected and the
enemy today doesn't fear us and they
don't respect us why would anybody
respect an enemy who's out of shape this
guy's going to run out of breath after
30 seconds
of I can't do this can you tell them to
stop let's take a break nobody takes a
break in war there are no timeouts in
war and G there may be time out hey
coach I'm out of breath you can't go and
say hey Hamas can you let's take a quick
30 second time out on this war here
let's take a quick 30 second let's take
a full full time out full timeout to get
a break that doesn't happen in war so
it's pretty embarrassing and pathetic to
say the least one thing is that you know
on my show when the sast we have all
these women on and we have these
conversations about what's going on with
modern day feminism and basically the
body positivity movement and I'm not
sure if you've seen the latest Victoria
Secret fashion show situation and just
all shapes and sizes and sort of
redefining what beautiful is and there's
zero uh fat shaming allowed there's zero
accountability hey you could as big as
you be as big as you want to be and the
problem with that is that we didn't
essentially look on the other side side
of the equation when it comes to men men
have no problem being like dude you're
you're complete slop you're completely
out of shape get it together but women
will not do that to each other they will
not hold each other accountable if
someone's big they'll like oh you're big
you're a queen or whatever but to see
that happening in the military to today
is just sort of uh indicative of where
we're at you know they said the
military's gone woke go woke go broke um
the exactly the new Victoria's um
but it it's I don't know if this is a
food thing are are you saying bring back
fat shaming in the military is that kind
of what you're saying that's exactly
what I'm saying slight buling I mean at
least not being a little bullying and P
it's funny it's funny you brought up the
gays and the military by the way their
their numbers are so down it went from
when we were in to don't ask don't tell
now it's we don't give a we need we
need you and this is a fun this is
random P this is a a fact did you know
in 1994 our government tried to use gay
as a weapon did you know that they they
were proposed to build the Department of
Defense $7.5 million to create a gay
bomb a bomb a chemical that when it when
it blew up Google if you think I'm lying
Rob look it up Pat this chemical would
hit the enemy Pat and make them
irresistible to each other something
tells me Vinnie that much like theb Le
that leaked somehow here in America
buddy go okay there you go gay bomb uh
informally known as a non-lethal
psychemon concept that was speculated
upon a research laboratory within the
United States Air Force the
unconventional idea involved the
dispersion of sex uh fur over enemy
forces with the intent of generating
Mutual sexual attracting among them
causing Mass
confusion and panic within their platoon
dating back to 94 the right laboratory
in Ohio a persecutor to the modern
United States Air Force research
laboratory drafted a three-page proposal
detailing several potential non-lethal
chemical weapons eventually acquired by
Sunshine project freedom of informative
act request explores a notion of the gay
bomb among other con can you can you
imagine this Adam we're fighting in the
Middle East and there's two Middle
Easterns like in a foxhole and the gate
bomb hits and he's like the smoke is
like air are you okay he's like no he's
like what can I do to help he's like
well get back there and like dude could
you imagine using like that's that's
that's the type of money that they were
wanting to spend way too many good jokes
with this man funny is that but it's a
fact wow you told me to find gems that's
a gem maybe they dropped a lot of G
bombs in a few different places in
America you ever go down if you ever go
down the rabbit hole of CIA and
Department of Defense drug and other
testing you will find that they were
trying anything a lot of it didn't work
but they were trying anything and they
would experiment with it so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here h